tests at ccsd show distance learning  could be hurting students in math and  reading  this data you're looking at there from  ccsd testing shows the projected  proficiency between third and eighth  grade  the expected math proficiency from these  maps tests for students in grades four  through eight is below  right now the national projection josh  curtis has four children at ccsd schools  and he says most of his children didn't  perform well and he's concerned about  the testing  for them to call this a standardized  test to when there's no  standardization whatsoever my  kindergartner  he his map testing he identified zero  out of 26 letters the fifth grader went  horrible she went  she declined slightly students in grades  three through six at ccsd are expected  to achieve  grade level reading proficiency at or  above the national average by the spring  84 percent of ccsd students took that  maps test how